Малышка Hallo Hamburg! Hey, was geht? Wir haben Platz! Wir haben so viel Platz! Wir haben so viel Platz! Dankeschön! Vielen Dank! Es ist so viel Platz! Schön, dass ihr da seid. Es ist mir eine riesige Ehre, für euch ankündigen zu dürfen. Er ist heute hier! Es ist Stefan Dietze! Vielen Dank.
Und obwohl er hier steckbrieflich gesucht ist, weil er hier seine Stromnachzahlung nicht zahlt, er ist in the House, Florentin Will! Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Ah, das ist nett. Sehr schön. Das ist nett. Wow, dankeschön. Hallo Hamburg! Es ist unfassbar, wir haben schon nicht mehr damit gerechnet, dass das tatsächlich passieren kann. Nein, herzlich willkommen zu grossen Tickets behalten, Ihre Gültigkeit-Tour. Ihr habt sie noch gefunden, eure Tickets, wo lagen sie bei euch rum? Vor allem, wer wart ihr vor zwei Jahren? Wir dachten heute Morgen, ihr schaut auf die Tickets und denkt, das habe ich mal gehört vor zwei Jahren. Das ist, ich höre nur noch gemischtes Hack, wir werden die beiden eigentlich nochmal, deswegen haben wir unsere Namen nochmal gesagt, damit ihr grob einordnen können, was hier passiert. Genau, Tommy Schmidt und Felix Lobrecht. Ich bin eigentlich außer Atem, nur weil ich erinnere mich auch. Ja, ja, ich auch, same, same. Seitenstechen, ein Gefühl, das ich seit 20 Jahren, glaube ich, nicht mehr hatte. Aber wir können dieses Performer-Ding machen, dieses nach einer, bei Let's Dance oder so, wenn die so eine Choreo getanzt haben, dann nachher immer so in die Kamera gucken und sagen, ja genau. Und man denkt jedes Mal, nimm das Mikro von deinem Mund, also es muss nicht mehr an deinem Mund sein, aber die wollen halt dann, so Performer wollen auch gerne zeigen, dass sie sich angestrengt haben körperlich. Als wäre Tanzen so anstrengend, die dann am Ende einfach da sind. Man könnte das eigentlich in jeder erdenklichen Alltagssituation machen, egal was man macht, weil ich meine, wir sitzen alle im Publikum, wir machen gar nichts, sie tanzen, wir haben keine Ahnung, wie anstrengend das ist. Du kannst eigentlich in jeder Alltagssituation, kannst du einfach irgendwie als Wurstfachverkäufer kannst du die Salami schneiden und dann... Aber ehrlich gesagt, so lebe ich auch mein Leben. Also es ist kein neues Phänomen für mich, wenn ich mich vom PC zur Kaffeemaschine und zurück bewegt habe, ist bei mir auch ein grosses.
Ich habe wirklich Seitenstechen, ich weiß wirklich nicht, was ich machen soll.
Arme hoch, Arme hoch. Was habt ihr nächstes Jahr vor? Habt ihr noch Bock, können wir noch einmal verschieben?
Aber Seitenstechen ist doch immer noch Arme hoch, oder?
Nee, das wurde geupdatet. Ich glaube, du musst jetzt zweimal im Kreis laufen und dreimal den Namen deines alten Sportlehrers rufen. Ja, genau. Und dann geht das weg. Bei Vollmond und dabei so Salz über die Schulter werfen. Zum Glück ist die Forschung da dran, dass Seitenstechen auch langsamer aufhört. Wow, wir fahren das erstmal wahnsinnig, dass ihr da seid. So viele Leute, so hoch auch, so grosse Menschen. Wahnsinn. Sind das Plätze, wo man lieber sein will oder weniger lieb sein will? Daumen gehen hoch, einer macht diese Geste, was soll die bedeuten? Es sei denn, wir sind jetzt den Rest der Show hier, dann habt ihr natürlich ein kleines Problem. Das ist natürlich für die andere Seite gut, aber … Und ich spreche so einfach die ganze Zeit? Weißt du noch, wie es geht? Weißt du noch, wie man Live-Shows macht? Also nicht, dass wir jemals wussten, wie man Live-Shows macht, aber ... Nein, keine Ahnung. Ich habe geübt, ich habe dieses, man legt sich auf den Boden und tut so, als würde man im Kreis laufen. Das habe ich geübt. Ich hoffe für euch, dass es so weit nicht kommt, dass wir nie an dem Moment sind, wo ich sage ... Bauchwelle. Vorsicht, und dann das mache, so wird es nicht kommen. Keine Angst, und dann habt ihr auch ein verdammtes Problem, weil ich das genau hier unten machen werde, wo ihr nichts seht, wo die ganzen reichen Aristokraten auf ihren dicken Polstern auch mal bestraft werden. Das Volk will auch Spaß haben. Ja, aber das habe ich nie verstanden. Ich glaube, die richtig teuren Plätze in so Opernhäusern oder sowas sind ja quasi einfach da. Das sind so dann diese, die so die Herzogen und so, die haben dann da gesessen, finde ich aber nicht den besten Platz. Das ist so der Platz, wo man dann noch so hinter die Bühne gucken kann so ein bisschen. Niemand singt dahin, das Orchester ist irgendwo unten, alles geht, der ganze Schall geht dahin, die hören nichts, aber es werden halt von allem gesehen. Ja, außer heute, heute spielen wir allein für euch, denn wir lieben reiche Menschen. Wir lieben reiche Menschen, es ist meine liebste Art von Menschen, muss ich sagen. Was magst du so an denen, was magst du so an denen? Ach, vor allem das viele Geld. Also wirklich, da bin ich, ja, es ist wirklich, das ist das Einzige, was mich passiert. Nicht der gute Humor? Nein, nein, gar nicht. Der Geschmack? Nein, ich mag das viele Geld einfach, dass man das auch ansehen kann, Leuten, die viel Geld haben. Was würdest du dir kaufen bei sehr viel Geld? Was würdest du generell anders machen, wenn du jetzt einmal so eine Million hättest? Ich habe tatsächlich nachgedacht über das Thema Geld. Die krasseste Zahl, die mir eingefallen ist. Was würdest du machen, wenn du eine Million hättest? Nimm das Tommy Schmidt. Ich glaube, ich würde... Der kennt, glaube ich, größere Zahlen. I don't know. Ich glaube, ich würde mir exzentrischere Sachen kaufen, als ich bis jetzt besitze. Ich benutze so die, ich habe so die Standard. Wenn du dir so ein Barbie-Haus kaufst, so sind alle Sachen drin, Kaffeemaschine, Topf, das habe ich, aber ich will noch irgendwas in meinem Haus haben, wo nach meinem Tod Leute fragen, hm, ja, war, also einfach so ein riesiger, drei Meter grosses Ohrenstäbchen, einfach so riesengross, so Ohrenstäbchen, die normalerweise für Elefanten verwendet werden, einfach so, die in der klassischen Zoausstattung nicht fehlen dürfen, aber in der Privatwohnung eher merkwürdig sind, so dass dann bei der Gerichtsverhandlung und bei meinem Erbverteilungssystem alle fragen, was war Florian Will eigentlich für ein Mensch? Was finden wir da noch? Ganz ehrlich, so ein großes Ohrenstäbchen würde mich bei dir jetzt auch nicht irritieren. Also es wäre... Ich liebe Ohrenstäbchen, es ist wirklich, es ist meine Droge, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Warum? Warum? Weil es einfach das herrlichste Gefühl der Welt ist, weil es verboten ist, weil einfach auf der Packung schon draufsteht, bitte nicht ins Ohr einführen.
Und ich stehe im Laden und denke mir, nee, klar, nee, mach ich nicht, nee, mach ich nicht. Im Kopf aber, oh ja, oh ja, bis zur anderen Seite, einfach bis es einmal drin ist. Und die Kassiererin auch so, Sie wissen, wie man es anwendet? Natürlich weiss ich, wie man das anwendet. Man nimmt das und also natürlich nur für die Ohrmuschschell, genau, außen und alles andere. Auf gar keinen Fall in die Ohren einküben. Wer würde das denn? Weil literally alle Bilder auf der Verpackung sind Leute, die das reinrammen bis zum Anschlag, das nicht machen. Nee. Nicht das machen, wo man denkt, dass es dafür ist. Ja. Ich werde immer angeschissen, wenn ich mir so Medikamente besorge für so eine leichte Erkältung oder sowas, dann hat man immer diese unangenehmen Gespräche, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, weil wo man immer überzeugt wird, dass man gerade nur die Symptome bekämpft und nicht die Ursache und dann habe ich dann so Vic Medi-Night, was auch immer, Vitamin C durchgängigst genommen und so und die immer, ja, sie wissen, dass es nicht gegen die Ursachen bekämpft, sondern das ist nur irgendwie, dass sie dann besser schlafen können, das ist basically einfach nur Alkohol und man denkt dann, ja, also ich bin ja hier hingegangen mit einem Ziel, ich habe ihnen diese Produkte genannt, ich will die jetzt mitnehmen, aber Apotheker wollen dann doch ab und zu raushängen lassen, dass sie so haarscharf in Richtung Arzt unterwegs waren. Ja, dass sie massiv überqualifiziert sind eigentlich. Ja, und dann aber auch so, man denkt so, nee, dein Job ist es jetzt nicht, also vielleicht ist es literally ihr Job, mir zu sagen, wie ich das benutzen soll, aber ich will nicht, dass sie ihren Job ausführen. Ich kenne das auch bei wenig anderen Berufen, dass ich so wenig will, dass sie mir sagt, wie ich das benutze. Ja, nee, das ist ein Minderwertigkeitskomplex. Ich meine, Apotheker ist im Grunde nur jemand, der hat einen teuren Laden. Ja. So, im Grunde, es ist halt einfach nur teurer. Ja, und es ist dieser Kittel auch.
Mehr ist es halt auch nicht.
Dieser Kittel.
Ja, aber was sind denn die tatsächlichen, echten, darunter liegenden Probleme, wo du vielleicht an dir arbeiten könntest, wo man jetzt sagt, nicht immer nur Symptombekämpfung, sondern was sind die tief liegenden Probleme, die dafür sorgen?
Ja, das Ding ist ja, wenn man dann sagt, was würden Sie mir jetzt geben, was die Ursachen bekämpft, dann sagt sie, dann müssen Sie zum Arzt gehen. Nee, das müssen Sie, dann müssen Sie was Verschreibungswichtiges nehmen, was Sie beim Arzt bekommen. Und man denkt, nein, nein, du bist mein Bypass, ich bin hier, um nicht zum Arzt zu müssen. Das ist die grösste Lüge aller Zeiten, fragen Sie einen Arzt oder Apotheker, sondern einfach einfach, fragen Sie einen Arzt. Apotheker, können wir da auch stehen? Können wir ein Oder kriegen? Kriegen wir ein Und-Oder vielleicht sowas? Der grösste Lobby-Efolg der Apotheker ist in dem Satz mit dabei zu sein. Ja. Ich glaube, das war eine Riesendiskussion, wo die unbedingt noch reinbekommen wollten, dass sie da in diesem Namen stehen, in diesem Werbetext stehen. Wir haben so ein Glück, dass wir über Apotheken reden, weil die gab es vor zwei Jahren auch schon und deswegen können wir das jetzt alles wiederverwenden. Wir haben nämlich ein Programm, wir haben wirklich ein Programm, nichts verändert. Also, falls euch auffällt, viel 2020er Humor heute Abend, also viel Crazy Frog und Gangnam Style. Der Dress, habt ihr dieses Dress gesehen? Ja, weil ich dachte... Blau und Gold, nee, was? Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich dachte Weiss-Gold und du dachtest Blau-Schwarz. Ja, ich, Blau-Weiss. Und jetzt hat er dem eine Ohrfeige gegeben, dem Kleid. Nein, das war letzte Woche. Das ist ja unfassbar. Das war letzte Woche. Es war ein verrücktes Jahr 2020. Wir machen nochmal so einen kleinen Revue heute. Übrigens, unsere letzte Show war auch in Hamburg vor anderthalb Jahren. Und ich sag mal so, die Corona-Gags sind nicht so gut gealtert, ehrlich gesagt. Zwei Jahre später steht man dann wieder hier und lacht, weil man so inzwischen einigermaßen die Situation gecheckt hat. Die Gags, die wir gemacht haben vor zwei Jahren hier auf einer Bühne auch in Hamburg, waren nicht so gut gealtert. Es war eher so, wie funktionieren Masken, haha, in Asien tragen die Masken, was für Dusselköppe. Ich erinnere mich noch an den mittlerweile sehr unangenehmen Satz, meine Oma aus Paloma hat Corona. Ein grosser Lacher damals, nicht so gut gealtert tatsächlich, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, der Rest, wir haben viel Dinosaurier-Sachen, das ist natürlich gut, das kann man 2020 und 2022 gut unterbringen auf jeden Fall. Aber habt ihr euch verändert in den letzten zwei Jahren, würdet ihr sagen, ihr seid jetzt andere Menschen, als ihr hier sitzen würdet vor zwei Jahren? Unangenehm ist natürlich, hat jemand, wollt jemand mit seinen Exfreunden, Exfreunde hingehen und die Beziehung ist vorbei? Ja, hier, okay, zerbrochene Liebe. Es gehen so viele Arme hoch. Ja, wer hat wen betrogen? Einmal. Ah, du bist jetzt eine andere Ex-Freundin. Mit dem gleichen Vornamen, eine Information, die einfach reingeworfen wurde, als wäre es nichts. Also du hast mit Rebecca Schluss gemacht, um Rebecca zu treffen. Und weil du ein großes Rebecca-Tattoo auf dir hast und dein Leben lang Rebecca suchst. Ja, ich habe leider leider schon Geschenke gekauft. Ich habe ein riesiges Ohrenstäbchen gekauft, das geht jetzt leider nicht mehr, kriege ich nicht mehr ungetauscht. Aber dann einen ganz kleinen Zettel mit Rebecca drauf, den man einfach austauschen könnte. Aber also hast du aktiv nach einer neuen Rebecca gesucht? Ja, wirklich aktiv? Wie geht das? Also du läufst einfach die Gähne und rufst. Naja, wer hat die nicht, Laurentin? Du schaust, du rufst einfach Rebecca und guckst, wer reagiert, oder wie läuft das? Wahnsinn! Das habe ich aber auch schon mal gedacht. Wahnsinn! Tinder aber mit Filter. Finder. Ja, aber ... Weiß ich nicht. Gut! Naja, das ist ein Brainstorming. Ja, ich meine, da ist Apple vor 40 Jahren draufgekommen. Das kann ich auch machen. Meine ganzen Freundinnen liegen im Finder. Aber ich finde das interessant, weil das heißt ja, deine Ex-Freundin ist auch Podcast-Ufo-Hörerin, wenn du zusammen mit ihr hängst. Das heißt, es ist recht wahrscheinlich, dass sie das hier auch gerade hört. Und wenn sie hört, er hat mit mir
Schluss gemacht, um mit einer anderen Rebecca zusammenzukommen,
müssen sie sich denken, so viel habe ich nicht
falsch gemacht. Also ich war
wirklich nah dran. Also es
hat nicht viel gefehlt.
I was so close, perfect woman.
Oder sie denkt sich, was war dann
das Problem? Der Name ja offensichtlich nicht.
Aber andere haben halt so einen Typ,
also vielleicht Aussehen oder optisch oder so. Du hast einfach einen Namen. Du liebst einfach den Namen Rebecca. Es ist ein Problem, dass die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, ihr, weil er wieder Rebecca, versteht, nur als Roman, sorry, falls Autoren im Raum sind, Entschuldigung, Dankeschön, vielen Dank, danke schön, das war's was habt, die haben wir jetzt raus! Ja, okay. Ohne Florene wieder Seitenstechen. Was ist das da oben, ist das für die Orgel? Wie bitte? Ob das für die Orgel sei? Ich kann dich nicht verstehen, wenn du da unten bist. Ja, ich weiß. Aber es ist wirklich für die Orgel, oder? Nein, das macht ja auch gar keinen Sinn. Die Tasten kann man ja nicht, bei Momenten die Tasten weggestellt, aber die Bank nicht. Das ist doch für die Orgel. Das ist auch der Moment, wenn du dein Kind fragst, welches Instrument möchtest du lernen, und die kleine achtjährige Rebecca sagt, Orgel, und die Mutter sagt, oh fuck, er geht jetzt jede Woche in die Leitzhalle. Und es ist das dritte Kind, erstes Kind, Piano, fuck, zweites Kind, Kontrabass, scheiße, drittes Kind, war kurz an Triangel, überlegt, aber dann Orgel genommen.
Und dann Orgel, einmal in der Woche beim Orgeltraining, ähm, ähm, nee, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, und der Vater dann immer Weihnachten, nee, spiel mal Interstellar jetzt, spiel mal Interstellar. Ja, aber ganz schwer, die meisten Menschen lernen ja Instrumente, um das begehrte Geschlecht zu beeindrucken. Sehr schwer für Orgelspieler. Wirklich so, wenn dann sagst du, ey, Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, wo fliegt denn den Weg zum Bahnhof? Ganz kurz, Entschuldigung? Da hinten. Ah, okay, Entschuldigung. Wie heissen Sie? Mirko. Ah, falscher Name, alles klar, gut, dann suche ich alles klar. Nächste, Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, wie finde ich denn den Bahnhof von hier? Einfach da geradeaus gehen. Wie heissen Sie denn, wenn ich frage? Rebecca. Okay, die nächste Kirche, die nächste Kirche ist zwei Stunden entfernt. Hast du Bock, mit mir in die Kirche zu gehen? In die Kirche zu gehen? Vielleicht, nur kurz, wirklich nur kurz. Das wäre echt viel zu creepy, jetzt mit mir in die Kirche zu gehen. Nur für Amel zu gehen. Vielleicht nur kurz, wirklich nur kurz. Das wäre echt viel zu creepy jetzt mit dir in die Kirche zu gehen. Nur 1,47, nur für Amelie. Nee, mein Ex-Freund wollte mich irgendwie auf den Altar bringen und so. Wie fühlst du dich? Es ist wahnsinnig schwer, es ist super schwierig. Ich weiß bis heute auch nicht, wie das funktioniert, wie Orgeln funktionieren. Ja, so. Und dann kommt das da oben und dann von unten herab. Ja genau, du hast dann so einen grossen Schlägel und mit dem haust du dann so auf die jeweils richtige Pfeife drauf. Das würde ich halt verstehen. Das könnte mein Gehirn verstehen. Ja! Wie aber so viel Luft in diese riesen Pfeifen reinkommt, dass die Luft so schwingt. Nein, nein, nein, da ist keine Luft drin. Du hast diesen Schlagzeugschläger, dann hast du so eine Armbrust und lädst dann diesen Schläger und dunk, feuerst dann auf diese Röhren ab.
Deswegen kann man heutzutage mit so Nerfguns so drr viel besser auch spielen. Ja, natürlich hat sie ja viel getan in der Orgelkunst, ne, wahnsinnig.
Also wirklich, sorry, aber wir könnten jetzt Top Ten besten Orgelspieler.
Okay.
Okay, bei mir auf Platz zehn ist ganz klar Werminow Gargazo. Oh, okay, alles klar. Ja, weil der hat halt so einen gewissen speziellen Anschlag. Ja, das stimmt. Der hat, der hört, der macht es eher so ein bisschen Vroom als jetzt so ein Vum. Ja, Platz neun für mich ganz klar Hans Zimmer, auf jeden Fall. Nee, du hast deinen Platz zehn noch nicht gesagt. Achso, nee, Platz zehn ist auch Garo Hermanus auf jeden Fall. Sisi, Sisi. Platz neun auf jeden Fall Hans Zimmer und ab dann heißen tatsächlich alle Rebecca, merkwürdigerweise. Acht bis eins, alle Rebecca auf jeden Fall. Aber das heißt also, deine Ex-Freundin war Podcast-Ufo-Fan, wir sind noch immer noch durch. Ich weiß, ihr habt das Gefühl gehabt und auch ein bisschen. Aber jetzt ganz, hör du mal kurz weg, gibt es eine Chance, dass du noch mal zurück, dass es noch mal. Heißt noch jemand Rebecca hier? Also wir haben ja mal, also tatsächlich, wir haben ja mal den Service angeboten, wir retten eure Beziehung, in dem, ja tatsächlich. Kann ich mich nicht rein erinnern. Doch, ich erinnere mich, als wir gesagt haben, falls euch irgendwas an eurem Partner stört und ihr zusammen das Podcast-Ufe hört, schreibt uns das und wir erklären im Podcast, warum es so nervig ist, wenn man ständig die Tür abschließt, wenn man auf die Toilette geht, weil vor wem hast du Angst? Wir leben zu zweit. Also wie, was ist hier das Problem? So was zum Beispiel. Und dann sagen wir das und dann kann der andere, der zusammen mit seiner Freundin oder Freund den Podcast hören, sagen, ah stimmt, das ist auch nervig, man muss es nicht selber ansprechen. Aber immer dann nervig, wenn man dann zusammen quasi zum Podcast irgendwie einschläft und dann kommt die Stelle und dann so, sie reden darüber, wie du, also wie eine Person immer den Panikgriff im Auto hält. Genau, ja, wir sind in der Spielstrasse, ja, wir sind im Zug, aber deswegen vielleicht die Chance, vielleicht können wir die Beziehung noch retten mit der alten Rebecca. Nochmal, okay, er ist sehr, sehr motiviert gerade, ja. So, es ist ja noch viel besser. Dann kommen wir, okay, dann kommen wir nochmal rein und fangen nochmal an, weil das war alles, das heißt, wer ist noch mit Exfreunden denn hier gerade? Okay, ich hole die Flipchart, ich hole die Flipchart. So, wir holen die Flipchart. Wir müssen das jetzt klären, weil ich das nicht gestanden habe. Ihr seid, glaube ich, die einzigen, weil die Ausgangsfrage war ja, wer in der Zwischenzeit Partner, Partnerin verloren hat und den dann umdisponieren musste und den Dödel mitbringen musste, die gar nicht Podcast-Uvo hören. Aber hört denn die neue ... Oh, er freut sich direkt mit der anderen Nachbarin, auf jeden Fall, wie heißt du, Entschuldigung mal, können wir, sorry, können wir ganz kurz alle Rebekkas hier hinnehmen? Gar keine! Doch, doch, ein Rebekkas, zwei Rebekkas, drei Rebekkas und jetzt kommt ihr alle mal auf die Bühne! Genau! Und man merkt, dass wir in Deutschland sind, weil niemand kommt auf die Bühne.
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Die ersten vier Reihen sind leer, weil sich rumgesprochen hat, dass wir Leute auf die Bühne ziehen.
Aber das heißt, es sind die neue Rebecca auch Podcast-Ufo-Hörerinnen. Und du hast trotzdem deine Ex-Freundin mitgenommen?
Ja, genau.
Wow!
Da waren wir doch gerade schon.
Okay, ich merke, der Raum hat das schon vor zehn Minuten verstanden. Ja. So, jetzt verliert er mich, jetzt verliert mich alles. Er hat gerade gesagt, die neue Rebecca ist auch eine Ex-Freundin. Okay, wie heißt seine neue Freundin? Das ist ja die Frage, die uns alle interessiert. Ach so, Single. Aber die, Rebecca, gefällt mir. Nee, ja. Okay, Idee, Idee, Idee. Wow! Und zwar, nicht nur möchte ich dir jetzt eine Freundin besorgen, ich möchte auch herausfinden, wie sehr deine Rebecca ist die tolle Theorie hält. Und zwar zwar mein Vorschlag wäre, du gehst kurz raus. Wir holen eine Rebecca und zwei Rebeccas, Fake-Rebeccas auf die Bühne. Du kannst Fragen stellen. Du kannst Fragen stellen und musst dann wie in dieser alten Show, die es gibt, aber ich weiss nicht, wie sie heisst. Wer hat's gedacht, wer hat's gesagt, wer hat's gemacht? Herzblatt, sag mal, bist du komplett bescheuert? Wer hat's gedacht? Es gucken mich ganz viele Leute mit Masken und grossen Augen an und sagen... Wer hat's gedacht, die grosse Datingshow auf.1, haben wir nicht alle Erinnerungen dran? Aber so fing doch der Film Catch Me If You Can an. Und der fing ja nicht mit Herzblatt an. Also vielleicht die amerikanische Version von Herzblatt. Der fing aber auch nicht mit Wer hätt's gedacht an. Nee, das stimmt. Wow, aber das ist natürlich die Frage, also wir dürfen ihm eigentlich nicht sagen, wer die echte Rebecca ist, und dann schauen wir in zehn Jahren nochmal, wir schauen in zehn Jahren nochmal, ob du in einer glücklichen Beziehung lebst und dann sagen wir, sie heißt gar nicht Rebecca. Und dann hast du das tiefer liegende Problem vielleicht nicht geheilt. Aber Wahnsinnsgeschichte. Zwei Ex-Freundinnen, beide Rebecca, heute Single, heute Abend nicht mehr. Das ist vielleicht ... Das wäre eigentlich ziemlich cool. Wahnsinn, er ist stark. Hat jemand noch so ein Namensding? Ist das so ein Ding? Hat jemand einen Namen, mal ganz kurz. Haben wir Namen? Niemand, kein Name dabei. Aber sei froh, dass es Rebecca ist, oder? Ich meine, wenn es jetzt irgendwie Xerofani oder sowas in der Ecke wäre, dann wäre es einfach schwieriger.
Ja, da hast du dir schon was Gutes überlegt, das hast du schon clever gemacht. Aber das verstehe ich generell nicht. Also klar, Tinder hat das inzwischen so eingeführt mit Kategorien, so dass man unten dann schon gemeinsame Interessen oder so sieht. Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum man nicht danach geht, erst. Also eine App, wo es halt,
irgendwann kommt mal das Foto oder sowas, aber erst kann man halt durch ... so sieht. Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum man nicht danach geht, erst. Also eine App, wo es halt
irgendwann kommt mal das Foto oder sowas, aber erst kann man halt durch Kategorien swipen und
dann bleibt halt so eine Handvoll Rebeccas über und dann kann ich mir entscheiden und die sind ja,
weil, na ja, Leute, also klar, Optik spielt auch eine Rolle, aber uns geht es auch alle um die
inneren Werte. Ja, uns geht es darum, ich suche meine Traumfrau, die auch einfach Ohrenstäbchen
liebt, wo wir zusammen, wo wir zusammen ein Ohrstäbchen nehmen und mein linkes Ohr und
Vielen Dank. spielt auch eine Rolle, aber uns geht es doch alle um die inneren Werte. Ja, uns geht es darum, ich suche meine Traumfrau, die auch einfach Ohrenstäbchen liebt. Wo wir zusammen ein Ohrstäbchen nehmen und mein linkes Ohr und ihr rechtes. Die berühmte Szene. Ich drehe ganz leicht und das war's. Das ist unsere Erotik. Mehr passiert nicht. Während das Podcast-Ufo läuft, wo die sagen, wie sehr man das hasst, wenn man gemeinsam Ohrenstäbchen benutzt. Du verstehst, was ich meine. Du kannst dann anklicken, ich liebe Ohrenstäbchen und ich liebe das Podcast-Ufo. Und dann kannst du noch, ich liebe Florentin Will oder so anklicken. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht, die App finde ich gut, die finde ich gut. Die heißt das Podcast-Ufo. Gemachsame Interessen, Florentin Will. Und dann kriegen wir kein Match. Das ist natürlich auch schlecht. Ja, das wäre dann doof, ehrlich gesagt. Aber gut, okay, krass. Beide Rebeccas hören das Podcast-UFO. Könnt ihr nicht zusammen was starten, so die Ex-Rebeccas, dass ihr einen Podcast macht oder irgendwie sowas. Die beiden und dann nochmal so richtig so alles an ihm auseinandernehmen, so jede kleine Charakterschwäche einfach aus doppelter Erfahrung. Ich würde es mir anhören, ich finde es nicht schlecht. Sicher auch nicht so schlecht. Der grosse Rebecca-Podcast eigentlich. So die Zerstörung des, wie heisst du? So, habe ich wieder nicht verstanden. Jetzt habe ich Herzblatt verstanden. Jetzt hast du Liebe verstanden. Sag mal, bist du eigentlich Schwerhörig? Ja, ich glaube doch. David hat ja gesagt. David. Ich glaube, ist da irgendwas hinter den Ohren? Lass mich mal kurz... Ne, ne, mal ernst. Sorry, nicht das jetzt irgendwie... Aber ich glaube, wirklich, dass wir das... Oh ja, ich hole mein Etui. Das wäre so lustig. Mein Etui raus. Das wäre so lustig, wenn es von Florentins Essentials wäre. Erstmal, generell, jeder kennt diese GQ Essentials, Prominente, stellt ihre Sachen vor. Was wären deine zehn Essentials? Ohne Stäbchen, Manner? Ich habe auch Seven vs Wild gesehen, Leute gehen in den Wald und dürfen nur sieben Sachen mitbringen. Ich würde sagen, sechs Wattestäbchen. Sechs Wattestäbchen und Schlafsack. Nee, nee, nee, komm. Also eine Packung Wattestäbchen ist dein eine Essential. Nee, dann sechs Packungen. Wirklich, fuck it, fuck it, ich kann da ohne das nicht leben. Ich hab Salz, hätte ich mitgenommen, Salz. Einfach nur Salz? Schon noch sechs andere Gegenstände? Ja. Tarp hätte ich nicht mitgenommen, weil ich nicht wusste, dass es existiert. Ja. Zelt hätte ich mitgenommen. Ich hätte ein Auto mitgenommen oder irgendwie sowas. Alles, was man kriegt. Ticket zurück. Ich will ein Bagger.
Nee, das ist so funktional. Ich will ein U-Boot.
Ich will ein U-Boot und ich will ein Bagger und ich will vier Tischtennisplatten.
Bungalobelig.
Macht was ihr heute mit mir.
Ich hätte Salz mitgenommen, aber ich glaube, ich wäre damit nicht gut gefahren, weil ich dafür, ich hätte nichts gefangen für Salz.
Also wo Salz eine sinnvolle Zutat gewesen wäre.
Du meinst, wenn du dann ein Kaninchen irgendwann fängst und dann nach langer, langer Reise hast du extra noch ein bisschen Salz mit aufgehoben und kannst das dann braten? Ja. So was in der Richtung. So ein schöner Moment, dass du nicht vergisst, wie es war, als du noch nicht in dieser Sendung warst, vor vier Tagen. Das habe ich auch die ganze Zeit gedacht, wo dann alle Leute an Tag drei über die Isolation geweint haben. Also es war eine Show, wo um sieben Tage Influencer alle nicken, weil alle kennen das auch. Ist eine Datingshow quasi. Alle waren dann alleine im Wald und mussten dann sieben Tage lang überleben, durften nur sieben Gegenstände mitnehmen und waren halt alleine. Und ab Tag drei gingen die Tränen los, weil Isolation ein großes Problem war. Und ich als jemand, der häufiger mal einen Monat alleine ist, habe gedacht, was ist mit euch los? Also müsst ihr jetzt rumweinen? Aber ich verstehe die Abgeschiedenheit und so. Bei mir ist, glaube ich, auch das Wissen, dass da ein nahes Krankenhaus in der Nähe ist und so, hilft schon. Ich glaube, ich hätte da mehr so ein Horrordrama draus gemacht, dass dann irgendwie langsam die Ersten sterben oder er findet eine Leiche oder irgendwie sowas. Hätte ich gemacht oder so. Oder er findet einen echten Schlumpf oder so. Ah ja, das finde ich gut. Und er ist halt im Wald und sagt, bin ich jetzt bescheuert oder ist das echt gut?
Und es fängt ganz normal an. Du hast halt wirklich, das machen wir, Staffel …
Ja, lass uns das machen.
Wir machen so die neue Staffel …
Sieben Leute, brauchen Sie Leute? Sieben Hände brauchen wir, wer geht in den Wald?
Und dann so sieben Influencer und es wird komplett normal und auch ein bisschen boring,
dass alle denken, das ist normal und nicht gescriptet und dann findet einer einen Schlumpf. Genau. Und dann einfach so, einer kriegt den Schlumpf vorgesetzt und der kann ja niemandem erzählen. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich das Schlimmste. Dir passiert was Cooles, stell dir vor, du wirfst aus ganz weiter Entfernung so ein Apfelkerngehäuse und triffst aus zehn Meter in Mülleimer und so, oh, oh, oder, oder? Und es ist einfach niemand, zehn Kilometer um dich herum, niemand, das ist das schlimmste Gefühl. Und das jetzt mal hundert, wenn du einen echten Schlumpf triffst. So ein kleiner Schlumpf. Mal hundert. Hast genau ausgerechnet in deinem Kopf. Mal siebzig, zweiundsiebzig, mein Gott, wir runden doch. Stefan, wir haben gesagt, es ist eine Show, wo gerundet wird, okay, damit wir keine Zeit verlieren. Das ist nicht anders. Wir haben, also, für dich ist Schlf 100 Äpfelkerne, Äpfelkerne aus 100 Metern weg. Ich glaube, ich hatte meinen erfolgreichsten Moment einmal, als ich ein zusammengeknülltes Papier wirklich aus und ey, das waren wirklich zehn Meter ohne Scheiß, Leute, jetzt kein Bullshit, das wollen wir alle wissen. Jetzt kein Bullshit, das war wirklich, also wirklich von hier, von hier bis David einfach so, von hier und das war, das war War kein normaler Papierkorb, sondern so, ihr kennt die, so diese Kolben, wo nicht oben die Öffnung ist, sondern seitlich. Ja, so seitlich diese, ihr kennt die, diese Kolben mit seitlicher Öffnung. Jeder kennt die, niemand mehr spricht hier. Ich meine, nein, stellt euch vor, stellt euch ein großes Ohrenstäbchen vor, schneidet es oben und unten ab und dann seitlich so. Also sehr, sehr schwer zu treffen, aus grosser Distanz noch schwerer. Und ich habe geworfen und ich habe selber nicht daran geglaubt. Ich habe selber nicht daran geglaubt. Ich hatte schon, oh sorry, auf den Lippen, während das Papier noch in der Luft war. Die Entschuldigung war schon geschrieben, die Schamesröte stieg mir schon ins Gesicht. Und da habe ich getroffen! Und er rein und es haben zwei Leute gesehen. Zwei Leute? Zwei Leute gesehen, haben zwei Leute gesehen, Dankeschön. Es haben zwei Leute gesehen und ich war in meinem Leben nie wieder so stolz. Okay, und die sind jetzt hier, um das zu bezeugen, oder wofür hast du den Applaus? Hier sind Anton und Valentin, bitteschön, die ich extra habe einfliegen lassen aus Zürich, fand in Zürich statt, muss man nicht erwähnen. Ich dachte, oder war es wichtig, hätte ich es erwähnen sollen? Ja. Ja, ich mag Details, also warum nicht. Zum Roman in den letzten zwei Seiten, oh, übrigens, ich spiele in Palermo, sorry, war jetzt gar nicht, oh shit, sorry, war jetzt, habe ich jetzt leider vergessen, hat es überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt. Genau. Null irgendwie so ein Psychothriller oder so, er war in der Nähe von Den Haag tatsächlich. Aber ja, viel Spaß beim nächsten Buch. Was liest du als nächstes? Die letzten Zeilen muss man füllen als Autor. Was hast du Bock, was liest du als nächstes? Was liest du als nächstes? Was liest du? Ich könnte ja ein Buch von mir empfehlen, und zwar den zweiten Teil zu diesem Buch, falls du Bock hast. Ja, aber das ist ja literally hinter jedem Buch, die anderen Werke des Autoren. Ich glaube, jetzt kommt raus, dass ich noch nie ein Buch zu Ende gelesen habe. Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich wahr, wenn man sich mein Bücherregal anschaut, kein einziges zu Ende. Weil irgendwann denkt man, man hat es ja verstanden, so nach 40 Seiten bist du drin, ja, Schiff gilt als unsinkbar, fährt los, ja, was wird passieren, was wird passieren, Haie übernehmen das Schiff und machen jetzt ihre eigene Schifffahrt auf oder was, nein, jeder weiß, was passiert wird. Vielleicht bist du zu fantasievoll und deine eigenen Gedanken gefallen dir besser als dann der Ausgang. Ja, wahrscheinlich ist die Geschichte besser, als ich es dachte. Vielleicht, liest mal alles zu Ende, findest du heraus. Jesus. Die werden von einem anderen Schiff gerammt. Und dann müssen die alle auf das andere Schiff fliehen, und dann leben ganz viele Leute auf einem Schiff, und das ist witzig. Oder? Aber liest mal, hast du die Bibel zu Ende gelesen? Ah, fast. Ich mach die Geste. Man muss sich, für die Gedanken muss man sich warm machen. Mein Körper muss sich jetzt mental auf eine Lüge vorbereiten, ganzer Körperkraft. Nein, man kennt halt so die Highlights, man kennt Highlights, Geburt, Hasekreuz, so die drei grossen… Geburt, Hakenkreuz? Hasekreuz, so die grossen, die grossen drei, Jesu Geburt hier, was ist los, er macht nicht viel.
Nee, er ist nämlich wieder auferstanden.
Ja.
Der Hase, oder?
Der Hase, ja.
Oh shit, Spoiler!
Der Osterhase.
Auch kein Aufsicht in der Bibel gehabt, ne?
Genau wie der Weihnachtsmann, Erfindungen beides von Coca-Cola.
Vielleicht in Fussnoten, vielleicht auf der letzten Seite.
Oh, übrigens, Abraham war ein Hase, sorry, habe ich jetzt gar nicht, habe ich jetzt gar nicht, fuck, fuck, fuck, Matthäus ist einfach sehr vulgär. Fuck, fuck, fuck, scheiße, scheiße. Fuck, ich habe es vergessen. Sehr hart zu sich selbst. Matthäus, was der geleistet hat, der hat ein ganzes Evangelium geschrieben. Wir haben übrigens auch tolle Post bekommen in unserem Reddit von jemandem, weil wir haben ja den Humor in der Geschichte ein bisschen untersucht und wollten Gags herausfinden, die damals vielleicht in der Antike mal gemacht wurden. Und da hat uns jemand einen sehr langen, tollen Beitrag, den könnt ihr finden bei Reddit, geschrieben, weil er sich selber für Humor in der Antike, im Mittelalter interessiert. und da ist auf einen Wortspiel-Akrobaten gestossen. Und es ist grauenhaft schlecht, aber er freut sich so sehr, das gefunden zu haben, das müsst ihr unbedingt mal angucken und bewerten mit einem, wie macht man das, Daumen nach oben, fein nach oben. Aber es ist halt auf diesem, woher kommt ihr, Slavenjungen, die sagen aus Elli oder so, und er sagt auch Alleluja. Wow. Und unser Historikerfreund, Standing Ovations, von Hamburg, und unser Historikerfreund hat sich so gefreut, dass ich dachte, ja okay, aber jetzt ist die ganze Rubrik im Arsch. Also wenn sich ein Historiker so über diesen Pfund, wenn das die Messlatte ist für Humor in der Antike, dann war's das.
Aber ich mein, das ist ein enormer Druck. Stell dir vor, du musst einfach deine Gags in Granit meißeln, und jeder Granitblock kostet ein Sklavenleben, und der Sklave fragt so, okay, was ist der Gag, und du, ähm, pass auf, okay, äh, Hall, ähm, gib mir mal, gib mir eine Sekunde, gib mir mal. Nee, wir müssen das jetzt, wir müssen das jetzt machen. Okay, okay, okay, schreib, schreib, okay, fang mal an mit. Also, kommt ein, kommt ein Asyrer in die Bar. Okay, jetzt hast du wieder ein Jahr Zeit, bis ich das eingeschrieben habe. Okay, gut, vielleicht sind Asyrer-Gangstern auch out, weiß ich nicht. Schreib mal, schreib mal Hund, schreib mal Hund lieber rein. Nee, das erste Wort war jetzt das. Okay, er schaut sich um und fragt, wo ist Harley? Bitte? Wo ist Harley? Harley? Sorry, ich bin der Comedian, ich brauche eigentlich deine wertenden Blicke, brauche ich gerade gar nicht. Das lenkt mich gerade eher ein bisschen von der Arbeit ab, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, muss nicht dir gefallen, muss Leuten in
2000 Jahren gefallen, die das noch lesen, Entschuldigung, das bleibt für die Ewigkeit, okay? Millionen Menschen in Museen werden diesen Gag
lesen und wir sind bei Harley, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, du bist gut, du stehst nicht umsonst hier, du stehst nicht umsonst hier, du warst von deinen
zwölf Brüdern der Lustigste und deswegen stehst du hier und deswegen hast du diesen Job. Okay, und sagt der Barkeeper, Halleluja!
Vielen Dank. Du warst von deinen zwölf Brüdern der Lustigste und deswegen stehst du hier und deswegen hast du diesen Job. Okay, und sagt der Barkeeper, Halleluja. Okay, okay, der ist gut, schreib ihn rein. Und zweitausend Jahre später ein Mönch. Ja. Und das war's. Genau, zweitausend Jahre später in Hamburg in der Leitzhalle. Und dieses sehr trockene Husten immer dir ist.
War ja wahnsinnig trocken in der Vergangenheit, war ja alles wahnsinnig trocken.
Trockener Husten-Gags, auch ein Gag aus 2020.
Ja, tatsächlich, wir versuchen es noch unterzubringen.
Wir versuchen noch unsere Gags zu recyceln.
David, wie schaut's aus?
Hast du dich schon entschieden zwischen den vier Anwesenden Rebeccas? Wo stehst du? Ja, ja, nee, nee, okay. Können Rebeccas dann nochmal aufstehen vielleicht? Und vielleicht fällt doch da bei jemand, sorry, zumal ich hab mir nicht gemerkt. Kannst du aufstehen, oder ist es unangenehm? Wir kriegen das hin, wir kriegen das hin. Ja, okay, hey, dankeschön, sehr, sehr nett. Blond. Rebecca. So, und da oben war auch noch eine Rebecca, da oben war noch eine Rebecca. Okay, dankeschön. Und hier war okay. Okay, so erschleichen wir uns eine Standing Ovation wir rufen einfach Namen auf. Sehr, sehr gut, sehr schön, nicht schlecht. Hast ihr euch jetzt, ist direkt Konkurrenzkampf? Nee? Aber habt ihr euch vorher so erkannt und auch schon so, ihr beiden solltet, zugenickt? Gibt es einen eigenen Gruß unter Rebeccas einfach, wenn man so auf der Strasse aneinander vorbeiläuft und einfach so ein Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , Auf die gedachte neun. Auf die gedachte neun sagt ihr jetzt eure Überschrift. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, seid ihr bereit, sechs, sieben, wir müssen irgendwie die Zeit rumbekommen, acht, blau, grün, aus der Richtung auch noch grün, gelb. Blau, grün, gelb, sehr unterschiedlich. David, du kennst jetzt die Lieblingsfarben deiner drei Traum-Rebeccas, hast du schon eine Entscheidung getroffen? War dein Herzblatt dabei? Welche Lady soll es sein, Rebecca Gelb, Rebecca Grün oder Rebecca Blau?
Nochmal bitte? Grün-Fraktion. Grün-Fraktion? Alles klar, dann... Äh, ja. Gut, dann dürft ihr... Dann können sich alle anderen setzen. Dann dürft ihr... Dankeschön, vielen, vielen Dank an die Rebeccas, fantastisch. Dann dürft ihr jetzt gemeinsam ein Ohrstäbchen konsumieren. Ich finde es so gut, dass diese Halle akustisch so gebaut ist, dass dieser Höflichkeitsapplaus so laut ist, dass ich gerade dachte, das ist komplett unverdient für dieses Farbspiel. Das ist eine Halle für klassische Musik und für Menschen mit schlechtem Selbstbewusstsein, wo einfach jedes Husten zu einem tosenden Applaus wird. Aber das war echte Liebe. Habt ihr das gerade gemerkt? Hier war echte Liebe im Raum gerade. Oh, aber sie ist sauer jetzt, glaube ich, oder? Sie ist sauer. Warum hast du dich für die Grünen entschieden? Warum gerade die? Sie mal, oh, okay. Ah, ich verstehe. So, jetzt lassen wir dich und dich kämpfen auf der Bühne. Aber es ist so ein bisschen wie dieses, von hundert Leuten hat einer dein Geburtstag Ding, oder? Genau das gleiche, wie diese, dass es in einem Raum mit, sagen wir, wie vielen Leuten, tausend, zweihundert Leuten drei Rebekkas gibt. Wahnsinn. Wusstest du das so ein Rechenexempel? Stimmt vielleicht auch nicht die genaue Zahl jetzt. Aber denkt euch, eine erschreckend geringe Anzahl Leute braucht es nur, damit dein Geburtstag... Ach Stefan, du bist der Schlechteste in solchen Statistiken. Du sagst immer, ey, wusstest du, dass 40 Prozent... Ne, vier, ne. 400, ne, 400, ne. Ja, aber... Wenn 30, ne, wenn 30 Leute in einem Raum sind, sie wahrscheinlich, ne, wenn 130 Leute in einem Raum sind, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass alle denselben Geburtstag haben, 500 Prozent. Und ich so, wow, Stefan. Genau, entweder die Zahlen sind falsch oder so hoch, dass niemand sich vorstellen kann, was die Zahl ist. Nee, nee, vier, nee, fünfzig, vier, vier und ich so, vor allem, ich bin ja beeindruckt, ich bin ja leicht zu beeindrucken, egal was du mir sagst.
Ja, ich war gelangweilt von dem eigenen Fakt.
Mir ist das ja egal, ob es stimmt oder nicht, ich will einfach nur beeindruckt werden. Und Stefan, du beeindruckst mich regelmäßig. Okay, sag noch drei Gründe warum. Warum? Weil ich finde, dass du bist ein, also du, also du bist selten dehydriert. Also man, also kennt ihr dieses Unangenehme, ich habe so richtig Durst? Das hat Stefan nie, das ist ja entwürdigend, wenn jemand, also dieses, dieses zum Wasserhahnrennen und dann drei Gläser am Stück wegechsen, das hast du tatsächlich safe. Das sind die Top-drei-Eigenschaften von mir. Ja, du bist immer gut befeuchtet von innen. Du bist immer gut, du bist immer, also du hast nie so richtig hart Durst. Ne, also du hast nicht so, dass man sagt, mein Gott, er hat ja noch nie gehört, wie man trinkt. So, verstehst du? Okay, also ein grosses Problem bei anderen Menschen für dich. Mich nervt das, mich nervt das, ich denke, du bist seit 20 Jahren auf dieser Welt und hast nie gefunden, wie man Wasser trinkt oder wie man das macht.
Ich finde, ab neun Jahren sollte man keinen Durst mehr haben. Also so keinen, wenn ihr versteht, so richtig harten Durst mehr.
Übrigens auch nicht dieses, ich muss so doll pinkeln. Das ist irgendwann, also mit sieben, sechs, sieben Jahren sollte man das abgelegt haben und vernünftig Bodymanagement betreiben, finde ich. Das hast du auch nie. Nee, das soll aber jetzt nicht der zweite Fakt sein, weil das habe ich ja jetzt gesagt. Nee, aber das mag ich nämlich so gerne an dir, dass du auch dich selber loben kannst. Das ist mein Satz Nummer eins. Dass man dich… nee, das ist gut, das ist gut. Nee, komm mal her. Ja. Nee, im Ernst, das ist gut, weil Leute, lass dir mal was erzählen, setz dich mal auf meinen Schoß. Setz dich mal, komm mal her, Stefan, komm mal her, komm mal her, komm mal her, komm mal. Nee, komm mal, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, schau mal. Ja. Du bist jetzt als ... Ist das dein Handy? Du ... Onkel, Onkel Friedrich, ist das dein Handy? Soll ich es vibrieren lassen? Nein, lieber nicht. Guck mal, du bist jetzt alt genug, dass es nicht mehr scheißegal ist, was du sagst. Bis jetzt war alles, was du gesagt hast, scheißegal. Also meine zwölf Millionen TikTok-Follower sehen das anders. Ja, auch die haben dich nicht abonniert für das, was du sagst, okay? Woher deswegen dann? So, also, ab jetzt ist es wichtig, was du Leuten sagst. Und du wirst Leuten Komplimente machen müssen. Ja, okay. Ja, okay. Kann ich aufstehen? Nein. Okay. Du wirst Leuten Komplimente machen müssen. Aber es ist unangenehm, Leuten Komplimenten zu machen, weil es ist schwer. Man weiss nicht, was ist den Leuten wichtig, sagt man irgendwas Falsches, sagt man, hey, ich mag deine, ich finde es gut, dass deine Lieblingsfarbe grün ist und so, und dann finden die Leute das unangebracht. Und deswegen such nach Leuten, die sich selbst Komplimente machen, dann musst du das nicht mehr machen. Okay. Okay? Okay. Kann ich jetzt aufstehen? Hast du noch Fragen? Warum umarmst du mich immer so lange? Hm? Weil ich dich so gern hab. Mama sagt, ich soll dann einfach sagen, dass ich das nicht mehr will. Okay, dann danke schön, deine Mutter. Ciao. Sie ist nicht deine echte Mutter. Ja, es ist schwer, Mutterschaftstest. Nee, schwer bei Sketchen nicht in Richtung sowas abzuriffen. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich war über Weihnachten bei meinen Eltern und ich glaube, ich habe da so eine tickende Zeitbombe hinterlassen, die einfach in Familiendrama ausartet. Aber so völlig bewusst so. Ja, es war wie oft ein fehlgeleiteter Gag. Gut. Weil du bist ja nur so kurz in dieses, du gehst nur so kurz in dieses Wespennest-Elternhaus, rüttelst es einmal dran und rennst weg. Es ist ja wie so ein Klingelstreich und die müssen sich noch ewig mit den Bienen rumschlagen. Und ich habe tatsächlich meinen Onkel getroffen. Zufällig. Zufällig tatsächlich. Und dann meinte der so, Mensch, ey so Florentin, er so, du siehst echt aus wie dein Bruder. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ja, ja. Aber das liegt daran, dass mein Bruder und ich dieselben Eltern haben. Und dann meinte er so, hä, was, wie, also, also kein, kein, keine Lust auf Humor, keine Lust auf Spaß. Klingt so, als hättest du das Folgende nicht so richtig verstanden, was jetzt kommt. Und dann, und dann er so, ne, wie, wie, hä, wieso meinst du jetzt? Und ich hab noch einen anderen Bruder und hab dann gesagt, na ja, halt nicht so wie bei dem anderen Bruder. Und er so, was? Und ich so, na ja, also mein Vater ist ja nicht sein echter Vater. Und er, was, das kann doch nicht sein. Und mein Onkel dachte allen Ernstes, dass er an diesem random zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag erfährt, dass einer seiner Neffen gar nicht sein echter Neffe ist. Oh mein Gott. Und ich habe dann so wirklich nach quälenden zehn Sekunden, nee, halt als Spaß. Und er so, ja geil, war dann aber auf meiner Seite. Willst du noch was von Braten haben? Ja, und dann habe ich das meiner Mutter erzählt und meine Mutter war ausser sich und meinte, nee, da muss ich nochmal anrufen.
Nicht, dass der jetzt, nee, also solche Witze kannst du nicht machen, Florentin, der, nee, nee, da muss sich jetzt die ganze Stadt anrufen und muss überall klären, dass der wirklich mein Sohn ist. Und ich so, weisst du es wirklich? Und sie halt so, was meinst du? Und ich so, hat hier niemand Humor in dieser Familie? Niemand? Es wird nicht leichter. Aber ich glaube wirklich. Aber also entweder hat niemand Humor, unwahrscheinlich, oder der Witz war für alle Beteiligten ein bisschen zu nahe liegen. Das kann sein. Und du hast da literally in ein Westen-Nest gestochen. Ja, und das ist ein guter Punkt, weil ich glaube, wäre mein Bruder nicht so hässlich, dann hätte der Gag anders funktioniert. Weil ich sage mal so, es gibt, wir sind drei Brüder, zwei sehr gut aussehende. Und ein Schlumpf. Ich überlasse es jetzt mal euch, wer hier vor euch steht. Und ein, ja, du sagst Schlumpf und ein Schlumpf. Und deswegen war das auch sehr glaubwürdig. Aber ich glaube, meine Mutter hat wirklich das gesamte Dorf angerufen, mit der wahrscheinlich sehr merkwürdig anmutenden Nachricht, übrigens, ich wollte nur mal sagen, der hier, der David, das ist wirklich mein Sohn. Also gut, war es das? Wollen Sie die Brötchenbestellung für morgen trotzdem noch beibehalten, oder? Ja genau, bleib acht Brötchen, aber acht Brötchen also für meinen Sohn und mich. Also mein Sohn, der aus mir, also mit meinem Ehemann zusammen in einem verschwitzten Nachmittag in Ulaanbatu am Strand. Es war herrlich. Und dann habe ich ihn selber zur Welt gebracht, meinen Sohn. Ja, okay. Also neun. Sie kriegen den acht Brötchen zum Preis von sechs von sechs Brötchen. Ich will aber nur sieben, verdammt noch mal! Und wo wir grad bei dem Thema sind, wo wir grad bei dem Thema sind, du hast ja deine grosse, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Florentins Laugen-Geschichte mitbekommen habt, wahrscheinlich schon. Welche?
Laugen? Deine Laugen-Brezel-Geschichte. Florentin ist in der ganz heißen Sache auf der Spur, Thais ist alarmiert, wir wissen nicht genau, was das bedeutet, weil Thais ist immer alarmiert, aber hört man dann doch nichts mehr von ihr. Das ist, glaube ich, diese Gen Z, von der alle reden. Jedenfalls hat Florentin, du bist in einem grossen Komplott auf der Spur. Du hast herausgefunden, dass innerhalb von zwei Monaten dreimal die Preise für zwei Laugenbrezel, du bist der Coolste, du bist so cool. Sorry, ich muss einmal, sorry, ich war kurz verleitet. Warte, ich mache noch einen, dann. Das hast du herausgefunden. Okay, Achtung. Nice. Nice. Dankeschön. Und? Kann man sliden?
Nee.
Und zwar hast du das ja hinbekommen, ist das alles passiert in Köln. Ja. Da hast du den grossen Komplott mit aufgedeckt. Ja. So, heute war der erste Tag, wo ich quasi den Florentim-Wildtag hatte, ich bin in Köln eingestiegen, in den Zug und nach Hamburg gefahren. Und da habe ich mir natürlich nicht leben lassen, bei genau diesem Bäcker hinzugehen und habe zwei Laugenbräsel gestellt. Bei exakt deinem Bäcker. So, weil wir hatten ja, das war ja meine Hausaufgabe, aber wir sind alle überrascht, dass jemand die Hausaufgaben wirklich mal gemacht hat. Wir sind erst mal überrascht, dass du dich an die Hausaufgabe erinnerst. Das ist die Überraschung. Ich bin selbst sehr überrascht. So, und zwar habe ich dann bei dem Bäcker, bei dem du laut eigener Aussage nur 2,40 Euro immer noch zahlst für zwei Laugenbrezel. Ich habe auch nicht ganz verstanden, drei, das habe ich inzwischen wirklich vergessen, drei hätte es aber bekommen sollen für 2,60. Richtig, das Angebot besteht immer noch. Nein, nein. So, wir müssen hier nochmal ganz von vorne anfangen. Also, früher waren die billiger, jetzt sind sie teurer. Früher 2,10. Ich bin der Einzige, der dieses Wissen hat. Sie kosten 2,60 Euro, die Brezelfrau weiß aber, dass ich weiß, dass sie den Preis perfid in die Höhe getrieben hat, ohne die Qualität der Brezeln zu verbessern, was ich verstehen würde. Hat sie nicht. So, und deswegen, um ihr dreckiges kleines Geheimnis zu bewahren, verlangt sie den alten Preis von 2,40 Euro, obwohl ich weiß, dass das nicht der richtige Preis ist, ich auch den normalen Preis zahlen möchte, sie mir die 20 Cent zurückgibt mit einem perfiden Lachen. So, und ich bin da hin heute und habe es aufgenommen. Bitte, das ist nicht dein Ernst. Was hast du... Moment mal, Moment. Ich habe gedacht, ich kann ja vieles erzählen und lachte mir, ich nehme das Ganze auf. Die ganze Scharade. Okay, jetzt wird's kriminell. Nee, weil wenn die da wirklich so dieses Dynamic Pricing, ich habe da auch ein bisschen recherchiert, es kamen viele Nachrichten auch von den Betriebswirten, Betriebswirtinnen unter euch, alles ein bisschen weird, also manche sagen, das ist erlaubt, man kann einfach, solange da kein Preis steht, kann jeder behaupten, was er will, und dann kann auch einickers mal schnell acht, euren dreissig kosten und man kann dagegen nichts tun. Manche haben gesagt, das ist verboten. Ja, mach vielleicht bei dem Teil weiter, wo du Sprachaufnahmen in meinem Privatleben machst. Und dann bin ich heute Morgen zum Körneraufgang und habe es aufgenommen. Und ich bin neu in diesem Private Detective Game und dementsprechend ist ist alles ein bisschen, naja, also die ersten zehn Minuten sind unbrauchbar. Aber wie hast du es gemacht? Also wolltest du ein Selfie machen, während sie den Preis sagt, oder wie hast du das angestellt? Weil ich dachte ja, alle haben ja mittlerweile ihr Handy eh die ganze Zeit in der Hand und habe dann geguckt, vorher habe ich getestet, ob man Aufnahmen starten kann, dann den Bildschirm dunkel machen kann und quasi mit einem scheinbar gesperrten iPhone dahin gehen kann. So, ich spiel's mal ab. Und hier ist Where the Shit Show Begins, wenn man freundlich hört. So, wir brauchen jetzt absolute Ruhe. Und es fängt so…
Ich rede von Luftanhalten-Ruhe.
Es fängt so klischeehaft, da bin ich sehr stolz drauf.
Ich will das auch verkaufen für so Hintergrundhörspiele, wenn man irgendwie am Bahnhof ist,
weil es fängt so klischeehaft an.
Das wird nicht funktionieren. Hallo.
Hallo.
Hi, ich hieb gern zwei Laubenbrätchen.
Das war, danke schön.
Zwei Euro 60 bitte.
Wow. Zwei, vier, vier, vier, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei, zwei und dann machen wir das.
Super, dankeschön, tschau, vielen Dank.
Wow, also das kann man nicht schreiben, solche Dialoge, solche Geschichten schreibt man das echte Leben. Beim nochmaligen Anhören dachte ich, dass ich ganz schön höflich war. Ja. Dafür, dass zwei Sechzig für zwei Bresel extrem viel ist. Ja, wirklich. Aber niemand da, also lass mich nicht durch den ganzen Moment nochmal von vorne bis hinten, wir haben noch nicht ausführlich genug darüber gesprochen. Man geht hin, ich sag, hier kannst du Verlogen bräsel, die sagt zwei, 60, zwei Damen waren da, niemand hat mit der Wimper gezuckt, als ob da jetzt irgendwie eine andere Summe jemals im Spiel war. Wahnsinn, das ist verloben. Dieser ganze Laden will vertuschen, dass jemals zwei, 40, slash zwei, 20 im Rennen war. Aber die wurden nicht die drei Brezeln angeboten. Nein. Okay. Welch was für ein Spielchen spielten? Nimm die Laugenstange runter, nimm die Laugenstange runter. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, du bleibst jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig, ich stehe mal, Freundchen. Okay? Okay? Ich bin lustigerweise immer noch grösser, wenn du da auch jetzt hoch bist, ja. Ja, okay. Okay, okay. Aber warum wurden dir die drei Brezel nicht angeboten? Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist ausgelaufen, dieses wunderliche Angebot. Wahnsinn. Aber das heißt, der Beweis wurde erbracht, das ist ein bisschen wie große Pause gerade, irgendwie in so einem Schulhof, wo es einfach, wo man denkt, ist es machbar, sich gemütlich hinzusetzen oder ist das einfach unmöglich mit meiner pubertierenden Beinlänge? Wie lange kannst du knien? 14 Sekunden. Ja. Wirklich, knie einfach gar nicht. Bei mir auch, knien kann ich überhaupt nicht. Keine Chance. Ich war neulich lustigerweise zum ersten Mal, weil ich habe gehört, da ist bei mir in der Nähe so ein, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben Yoga so richtig gemacht, und da wurde bei mir angeboten, in der Nähe wird so gute Nacht Yoga gemacht. Also man kann da abends hin und es ist so ein beruhigendes Yoga, wo dann irgendwie so Musik läuft und dann kommen da Leute hin und es ist mega entspannt und einfach so halt, dass man danach gut schlafen kann. Es klang alles sehr nett, weil ich dachte, ich habe einmal in meinem Leben Yoga gemacht,
ich habe die ganze Zeit geschwitzt und es war unglaublich anstrengend und ich war nicht gut dehydriert.
Das ist die einzige Sache, für die du mich gerade gelobt hast. Ja.
Also das war ganz, ganz traumatisch und dann war ich da und es hieß eigentlich sehr beruhigend
und man hält einfach so lange Positionen die ganze Zeit, aber die Positionen waren halt wirklich ungelogen,
so dieses, mach so Kreuze mit deinen Beinen und dann legt man sich so hin, so. Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, ich will vor allem bei meinem ersten Mal da sein, nicht aufliegen. Ich will nicht als Noobie aufliegen oder will dann irgendwie, dass sie dann ihr Atmen ein und aus Ding unterbricht, um dann zu mir zu gehen, um meine Position zu korrigieren. Was ist sofort passiert? Nach der zweiten Übung kam sie zu mir und hat gesagt, entschuldige mal kurz alle und hat dann wirklich alle in ihren Positionen gelassen. Ja, und alle Augen rollen. Und ich war extra ganz hinten mit meinem Material, ich habe mich so aufgebaut und so. Sie kam ganz hinten zu mir und hat gesagt, ja, ich hole dir noch mal was und hat dann, und das hat sich komplett durchgezogen durch den ganzen Abend, hat sich bei jeder Übung, die wir neu gemacht haben, jede Position, die wir gehalten haben, neue Kissen gebracht und so neue Bolzen und so, bis ich irgendwann, und bei den letzten Übungen war das am Extremsten, da hatte ich dann so drei so riesige Kissen übereinander und lag da dann einfach, das ist kein Scheiß, so. Und dann war ich mit einem Kumpel da, dem ist das auch ähnlich passiert, der lag dann auch irgendwann so, aber bei ihm hat sie noch aus diesen Klötzen, so Bolzen, die man glaube ich einfach nimmt, damit man stabilisiert, keine Ahnung, so einen Turm gebaut und er lag auch so, aber seine Stirn lag noch oben drauf. Es war so weird, ich sag wie so ein Walross und es war so unenehm, und danach habe ich nicht gut geschlafen, weil ich die ganze Zeit gedacht habe,
das ist ein weirdes Cringe-Fest, das da gerade war.
Nee, das ist natürlich peinlich, du willst nicht so offensichtlich zeigen, dass du keine Ahnung hast.
Nein.
Du hast keine Ahnung, das ist das, was hier Hilfsmaterial gibt.
Ja, sind Sie Anfänger?
Dann gehen Sie einfach mal direkt auf die Hebebühne, einfach mal direkt, schon direkt und dann einfach.
So, und die anderen hier, sehen Sie, was der nicht kann, sehen Sie, dass er Anfänger ist. Ne, tatsächlich, ich kann wahnsinnig schlecht knien, natürlich auch schwierig für Heiratsantrag, also weil du, ich glaube, was du nicht willst, was du nicht willst, weil es ich suche, also ganz kurz, damit wir das zusammenfassen, damit wir beim Datingprofil beenden, ich suche eine Frau, die Lust hat auf Ohrenstäbchen und schnell antwortet. Das wäre, also ja, nein, ist egal, einfach nur schnell, schnelle einfach, schnelle Reflexe einfach so. Wo kommst du her, wie alt bist du? Schatz, du wolltest mir doch, du wolltest gerade was sagen? Ja, hi Rebecca, du. Jetzt setz dich doch erstmal, wir haben noch diese schöne Steak gerade bekommen. Ja, danke. Du, pass auf. Cheers, cheers erst mal. Ja, cheers, dankeschön. Du, eine Sache. Willst du dich noch mal hinsetzen oder so? Ja, vielleicht. Dankeschön. Nee, vielleicht, also eine Sache. Du, weil wir kennen uns jetzt, also wir haben uns ja damals bei diesem Live-Podcast kennengelernt. Ja, vor zwei Wochen. Genau. Und ich dachte, es hat sich angefühlt wie 2021, aber es war schon letzte Woche, merkwürdig, komisch. Man vergisst manchmal die Daten wegen Covid. Komisch, ja. Und ja, also, wie bitte? Sorry, egal, sorry. Und ja, wir haben uns direkt gut verstanden. Ja, fand ich auch. Und also ich wollte erst mal ein paar schnelle Fragen dir stellen, einfach damit du so ein bisschen reinkommst. Vielleicht ein kleines Spiel, wir lassen dir einfach ein Spielchen machen, ich stell dir eine Frage … Und es geht darum, dass ich schnell antworte … Du versuchst so schnell es geht zu antworten. Okay, okay, ja, kriege ich hin. Alles klar, welcher Wochentag ist heute? Mittwoch. Okay, welcher Monat ist heute? März. Okay, das war ein bisschen langsam. Vielleicht mal einfach nochmal. Welcher Wochentag ist heute? Ja, weil du mich so nervös machst. Okay, welcher Monat ist heute? Februar. Was ist dein Lieblingsevangelium? Matthäus. Willst du mich heiraten? Okay, ich stehe kurz wieder auf. Sorry, ich stehe kurz wieder auf. Wolltest du mich gerade kurz heiraten? Ja. Und jetzt hast du es dir anders überlegt. Nee, ich wollte einfach nur ... Du musst mir schon ein bisschen mehr Zeit geben, das ist alles ... Nee, sorry. Das geht so schnell. Sorry, es ist ja geht, ich muss auch anders. Weißt du was, mach's gut. Was geht dich? Ich suche mir die vierte Rebecca. Es gibt unendlich viele Rebekkas in dieser Welt. Rebeccaen. Worauf stehst du? Rebeccaen. Rebecca, Rebeccaen. Aber drei Rebeccaen zum Preis von zwei. Und dann ist das Problem. Gute Frage, drei Drei Rebecken oder zwei Elisas? Andersrum gibt's wesentlich mehr Sinn. Drei Elisas oder zwei Rebecken. Was ist dein Kurs? Was ist dein Kurs beim Rebecca? Leute! What the fuck? Wenn er jetzt ... Er könnte jetzt einmal rumlaufen, theoretisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob er das weiss. Ja, er weiss es. Geil, weil wir ja über den Becker geredet haben, geil. Ja, Rebecca. Er hat eigentlich der cooleste Name gewesen für unseren Sketch gerade. Du, ich arbeite immer noch an einem Roman, Re-Becker. Wo wir gerade vor einer halben Stunde bei dem Thema Wasser waren, fällt mir ein, apropos Wasser,
ich war gerade hier eingecheckt um die Ecke im Hotel und an meiner Wand steht, ohne Scheiss, und es ist lächerlich passend für diesen Podcast, Dinosaurens drank the same water.
Das ist das Wand dazu.
As who?
We.
We as a human species. Fecies. We as a human species drank the same water as the dinosaur did before. Und das soll uns sagen... So, und ich dachte erst, mein erster Gedanke war bei allen von diesen Wandtat Wand-Tattoos, immer so, ach, blame. Dann dachte ich, ach, vielleicht ist da ein bisschen deeperes Meaning dahinter. Und dann dachte ich, nee, das ist einfach nur unsinnig. Ja, also wir fangen mal an. Entweder es soll uns sagen, nimm dich mal nicht zu ernst. Moment. Weil selbst ein riesiger Dinosaurier, also nur weil du jetzt, oh, ich trinke Wasser, oh, ich bin der feine Stefan, ich trinke ausreichend Wasser, hu hu, ich bin nicht ausgestorben, jetzt riecht es mir negativ aus. Nee, bist du nämlich immer noch kein Dinosaurier. Was bedeutet dieser Spruch? Ich glaube, wie cool ist das denn, selbst fucking Tyrannosaurus Rex hat auch das gleiche Wasser getrunken, auf dieser Erde wandernd, wie wir heutzutage. Was ja daraus folgt … Wir sind genauso cool wie Dinosaurier. Slash uncool. Slash federig. Ja, da ist natürlich die Frage, wann ändert man diesen Wandspruch ab, wo man sagt, leider, wann fügt man leider hinzu, einfach um es noch zu retten mit dem aktuellen wissenschaftlichen Stand. Ich bin kurz davor, woanders zu klopfen und zu wissen, was bei denen steht, weil ich glaube, es sollen einfach coole Sprüche sein. Und bei mir steht halt, did you know, dinosaurs drank the same water as you. So mitten in der Nacht, drei Uhr nachts, so panisches Klopfen. Ja, sorry, es ist super spät. Tut mir wahnsinnig leid, dass ich Sie mitten in der Nacht störe, Töne und so freu.
Sorry, ich bin direkt vom Zimmer nebenan.
War ich zu laut?
Sorry, meine Frau.
Sorry, ich bin völlig außer Atem.
Okay, nee, nee, nee, okay, nee, kein Problem.
Nur, ich war sorry, Töne.
Ich wollte nur mal fragen, ergibt Ihr Wandspruch auch keinen Sinn?
Mein Wandspruch? Ihr Wandspruch, weil ich... Ja, dann kommen du doch erstmal rein, kommst du erstmal rein, beruhigen Sie sich. Gerne. Ziehen Sie die Schuhe aus, warum Sie sich eine Jacke angezogen für den... Ich bin völlig außer mir. Das ist meine Frau, Rebecca. Guten Abend, guten Abend. Der Herr will sich nur unseren Wandspruch angucken. Oh, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nur wissen, ob ich der Einzige bin, ich konnte nicht schlafen einfach. Komm, wir gucken uns mal den Wandspruch an. Was steht da? Okay, es geht auch wieder um Dinosaurier, okay, alles klar, da scheint ein Thema zu sein. Did you know, the dinosaurs also ate Kohlenhydrate? Wie haben Sie diesen Spruch interpretiert? Ich sehe ihn gerade zum ersten Mal, aber irgendwie, also ich schätze, weil die die gleichen Sachen essen, weil die gleichen physikalischen Gesetze für sie gelten. Okay, dann bin ich ja beruhigt. Dann wünsche ich noch einen schönen Abend. Das wollten Sie nur wissen. Ich wollte nur wissen, ob Ihrer auch verwirrend ist. Wer auch immer die geschrieben hat. Ist Ihre Minibar auch leer? Das ist meine Frage. Ja, tatsächlich. Jetzt muss ich es sagen. Komm, wir gehen zusammen in das andere Zimmer, um herauszufinden, ob deren Minibar auch leer ist und was deren Bandspruch ist. Aber ich meine, ist es, also ich sage, sorry, aber du bist Autor? Nein. Da kriegt man ja wahrscheinlich manchmal auch so Anfragen, jetzt klar, also du wahrscheinlich flackern wir die ständig ein, Tarantino will, dass du da nochmal drüber guckst, hier irgendwie Leo Caballesi will sein nächstes Regiedebüt feiern und braucht jetzt jemanden, hier hast du dann nicht Lust, das mal zu schreiben, Stranger Things Staffel 5, aber kommt da auch mal so ein Zettel, so irgendwie drei Sinnsprüche für Hotels? Marriott's Wann-Tattoos. Ich will sofort ja sagen. Stimmt, ja, irgendjemand muss das ja auch schreiben. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass du ein Hotel kaufst und das ist mit dabei, sondern jemand muss das schreiben. Das sagt nicht mehr. Irgendein Autor sitzt da bei irgendeinem schlechten Kaffee und denkt sich die Fussstapfen von Dinosauriern sind grösser als deine. Und wo sind sie jetzt? Cent. Die … Wir machen Gangster ausschließlich für Apple-Nutzer. Knochen, die Knochen von Dinos auch vor allem aus Calcium, trinken häufiger mal Actimel. Warum schicken Sie uns jeden Spruch einzeln per Mail? Aber führ uns mal ein in die tolle Welt, weil wahrscheinlich haben viele Leute nicht so ein aufregendes Leben wie du. Das glaube ich. Ich glaube, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass die lustigste Arbeit ja eigentlich bei so Videospiel-Autoren ist, weil da hast du ja unendlich viele Bäume, verschiedene Wege, die man lang gehen kann, und überall spricht, gerade bei so modernen Open-World-Spielen, spricht ja überall halt irgendwas. Du musst ja wahnsinnig viele so random Gespräche im Hintergrund einfach dichten. Das ist doch ein geiler Job. Also so, dass sie, wollen sie speichern, ja, nein. Ich meine, irgendjemand muss das schreiben. Eher das, du gehst so eine Barszene. Kritischer Schaden, ich meine, irgendjemand muss das schreiben. So irgendjemand muss das doch schreiben. Aber du gehst zum Beispiel durch so eine Barszene und gehst halt an fünfzehn Leuten vorbei, die belanglose und für die Story komplett irrelevante Gespräche führen. Ja. Das ist doch eigentlich geil. Und so, also sowas hast du schon mal geschrieben? Das würde ich gerne machen. Gibt es irgendwas, was man so im Alltag liest, das du geschrieben hast? So jetzt irgendwie so ein flotter Spruch hinten auf einem Lkw drauf oder so. Oder irgendwie so ein… Meiner ist auch nur zwölf Meter lang oder so. Sowas genau. Ja, oder einfach so ein Sticker auf so einer Stossstange oder irgendwie sowas drauf. Baby an Board, das habe ich zum Beispiel. Baby an Board ist von dir der erfolgreichste Stossstangensticker. Ja. Wow. Und einer ist auch noch von mir, kriege ich den jemals wieder ab. Das ist ein Sticker. Ah, geil! Den kann man sich draufkleben. Geil. Und da steht einfach drauf, kriege ich den jemals wieder ab. Ey, wer auch immer ziehen geschrieben hat auf Türen, der muss ja wirklich wahnsinnig viel Geld bekommen. Einfach überall an jeder Tür. Aber wo sich gerade extrem kreativ ausgelebt wird, ist doch bei Toiletten. Klar gibt es immer häufiger Unisex-Toiletten, aber wo noch Herren und Damen sind, ist immer häufiger das H und das D weg zu so weirden Symbolen. Also nicht nur auch ein Mann oder eine Frau, sondern auch teilweise so ganz weird. Also ich war, ich war in Köln war irgendwie so ein Restaurant und da war, keine Ahnung, war ein Bild von Dick und Doof und auf der anderen Seite war ein Bild von Lüde Finesse. Und man denkt, what? Und man denkt so, also vielleicht ist es so ein subtiler Hint, irgendwie es ist egal, ihr könnt auf jedes Klo gehen. Ja. Oder das ist so ein Rätsel, was wie Captures langsam zu kompliziert wird für mich. Ja, es ist schwierig. Ich bin offensichtlich kein Roboter. Ich meine, ich bin zwar dick, aber ich würde mich nicht als doof bezeichnen, also das schon mal nicht, aber es ist schwierig. Kannst du Captures noch lösen? Ne, sehr oft tatsächlich nicht. Sehr oft kann ich es nicht lösen, weil was ist ein Verkehrsschild? Also zählt die Stange dazu? Ja, exakt! Zählt das am Boden dazu? Ampel. Was ist es eigentlich genau? Klick auf die Ampel. Was ist, wenn das so schräg nur ist? Woher soll ich wissen, ob das ein Verkehrsschild ist? Es könnte auch so ein länglicher Mülleimer zum Beispiel sein, der wahnsinnig schwer zu treffen ist. Ja, auch bei diesem Klick auf den Lkw oder sowas, und dann klickt man ja erstmal auf das Bild, wo der meiste Lkw drin ist. Und dann hast du ja noch ganz viele Bilder, wo der Lkw noch so im Anschnitt ist. Und ich weiß, meinen die das jetzt auch noch? Nee, ich zweifle... Ernstliche Frage auch einfach. Ja, vor allem, wenn du es halt dreimal nicht schaffst, denke man sich, okay, vielleicht verdiene ich es einfach nicht, mich auf diesem Single-Dating-Plattform anzumelden. Vielleicht verdiene ich keine Liebe, wenn ich es anscheinend nicht hinkriege, einen Lkw zu identifizieren. Vielleicht bin ich auch einfach ein Roboter. Vielleicht ist das der Moment, das ist vielleicht fest wie den Roman, das ist auch geil, dass du am Ende wirklich merkst, sie sind offensichtlich, ich weiß nicht wie, dann kommt dann so ein Pop-up, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es denn sagen soll, aber unsere Tests haben ergeben, dass sie ein Roboter sind. Das ist jetzt für sie wahrscheinlich... Liebes Pop-up, erst mal, du bist das gefühlvollste Pop-up, was jemals kam. Ja, das muss auch irgendjemand schreiben, der muss sagen, welche Fehlermeldung kommt, wenn man zu oft den Roboter-Test nicht bestanden hat, kommt dann so ein, hier ist eine Telefonnummer, hier ist so ein QR-Code, rufen Sie da an, da kann man Ihnen helfen, da gibt es so Anonyme-Roboter-Gruppen und sowas. Ich weiß es auch nicht, ist schwierig. Bist du Roboter, hast du das Gefühl, bist du Roboter? Ich wollte als Kind immer Roboter werden. Weil du lieferst ja ab wie eine Maschine, muss man ja mal sagen. Hey, nee, nee, nee, nee, hätte ich mir, sorry, das finde ich jetzt echt uncool von dir zu sagen, weil du hast mir verboten, Skateboard mit auf die Bühne zu nehmen. Okay, kleiner, kleiner, intimer, privater Diskurs. Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen das nicht ansprechen. Nee, weil ich habe hier das gesehen und mein Leben lang erzähle ich, ich kann Darkslide. Für alle, die nicht wissen, was ein Dark Slide ist, lame. Zweitens, Dark Slide bedeutet, wenn man mit seinem Skateboard fährt und dann, so Sliden kennt man ja, wenn man da so rumkratzt, und das macht man aber auf der schwarzen Seite des Skateboards. Man springt also, dreht es um und fährt dann falsch rum sozusagen. Und das kann ich, aber, und ich sehe es an euren Gesichtern, das glaubt mir niemand.
Nein, nee, niemand glaubt mir das. Wobei deine Vans sagen, ja, kann er. Und deswegen wollte ich heute eigentlich, weil wir hier auf der Bühne einige Stangen angebracht haben und hier so, wir können alles sagen, es ist ein Podcast, wir können alles erzählen, was wir wollen.
Nur eure Reaktionen beglaubigt halt, was wirklich passiert ist. Und da hätte ich es leiden können, aber Stefan hat gesagt, nein, keine Skateboards, sonst fällst du rum und brichst dir was.
Buh.
Ja?
Weil ich meinen Boosted Board nicht mitbringen konnte.
Das ist ja nur ein Podcast, ne?
Sieht man ja nicht.
So.
Und was du auch nicht weißt, Stefan, ist, dass ich trotzdem Skateboard mitgebracht habe.
Wuhu! Nein! Wie. Nein, hast du nicht. Das hast du jetzt nicht. Ganz genau. Leg das weg. Ganz genau. Leg das weg. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, lass uns doch einfach die Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer entscheiden. Wollt ihr ein Darkslide sehen? Also, okay, okay. Alles klar, ich brauche ein bisschen Platz, warte mal, ich brauche ein bisschen Platz. Ja komm, ich stelle das mal weg. Warte mal, hier die Flipchart muss weg. Nee, du musst es lauter wegstellen. Okay, alles klar, ich bin ein bisschen nervös jetzt erzählen, weil es ist tatsächlich nicht so gar nichts leicht. Ich auch, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht, was passiert. Okay, pass auf. Also erst mal mega uncool jetzt, dass du es trotzdem mitgenommen hast, ne? Ja, sorry, aber ich bin einfach, ich bin ein Skater im Leben. Du kriegst ein Skatepark aus mir, aber ich bin trotzdem Skater. Ja, das ist das berühmte Sprichwort von Tony Hawk Hawkins. Okay, alles klar. Gut, ich brauche ein bisschen Konzentration gerade. Ja, du hast Konzentration. Okay, der Boden ist glatt, das geht schon. Das ist aber sehr leise, das Skateboard, ne, an sich.
Ich kenne die ja, die machen so ein bisschen so Geräusche auch, ne?
Ja, wir bräuchten so ein bisschen Skatepark-Vibe eigentlich.
Kannst du mal so Avery Levine oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja.
He was a skater boy.
Sorry.
Avery kommt noch mal rein.
Okay, alles klar, nur Skates.
Das ist ein Problem. He was a skater boy. Sorry. Avery kommt noch mal rein.
He was a skater boy. Alles klar, los geht's. Achtung, drei, zwei, eins. What? Wow! Oh, danke schön! Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Ist das krass. Dankeschön! Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Wahnsinn! Dankeschön! Und der wichtigste Move, das Skateboard dann aber auch mit der Hand zu fangen. Alles klar, dankeschön, ich tu es wieder weg, dankeschön. So, ich glaube… Aber was ihr nicht gesehen habt, was ihr nicht gesehen habt, ist, dass manche Leute im Publikum so das … Weil nichts passiert ist. Was? Naja, also … In diesem Beispiel, in diesem fiktiven Beispiel … Für mich ist nichts passiert, für mich ist das Alltag. Aber ich glaube, einigen Publikum, einigen Leuten ist eine Entschuldigung fällig. Wir haben ein paar Leute mit dem Kopf geschüttelt, als ich gesagt habe, ich könnte in Darkslight. Möchtest du dich jemanden entschuldigen? Wir haben Zeit. Wer will anfangen? Wir haben Zeit. Wir haben die Halle noch. Gute zwanzig Minuten. Willst du dich jemanden entschuldigen? Alles klar, ist angenommen. Ist angenommen. Sehr schön. Vielen Dank für den einzigen ehrlichen Menschen in diesem Saal. Aber wir gefällt … Stefan Tietz eingeschlossen. Ja, sorry. Boah, das ist anstrengend. Auch hier ist leicht angepisst. Ja, mein Gott, du bist halt auch nicht mehr der Dünste. Aber ich meine, du, gelernt ist gelernt. Ich kann halt nur diesen einen Trick, ich kann nur einen Darkslide. Also jetzt irgendwie alles andere, Olli oder sowas, ging gar nicht, aber den kann ich. Aber weißt du, wo ich schon wusste, dass du ein Dark Side kannst? Weil warum solltest du den Namen kennen? Ja, das ist natürlich … Oder vielleicht Playstage, Tony Hawk. Weißt du, warum ich den Namen kenne? Weißt du, warum ich den Namen kenne? Na, du es kennst. Weil ich ihn erfunden habe. Damals, 1982, Seattle, Untergrund, dem Edeka. Seattle, die grosse Skatingstadt. Schön, ja damals schon, damals war das die Skatingstadt, bevor hier Tony Hawk auskam und es populär wurde. Und da habe ich natürlich ein paar Rollen gedreht mit meinen, mit meinen Homies und meinen, äh, Peoples, Peoples. The Peeps. The Peeps. Mit Little Pete, mit dem Dave. Damals hieß es noch Big Pete, damals hieß man Big, heute heisst man Little. Das war tatsächlich unterschiedlich, weil einfach die Namen ausgegangen sind, deswegen muss man irgendwann anfangen, das in den ersten Teil umzuhinden. Ja, völlig richtig. Es war eine schöne Zeit, es war eine schöne Zeit. Es war eine schöne Zeit. Ich habe ein bisschen Muskelkater wieder, muss ich sagen. Arm hoch. Aber es ist halt dieses Ding auch. Dafür ist mein Pullover zu kurz, wie euch vielleicht aufgefallen ist. Es ist einfach so, man geht morgens aus der Haustür in Weiß, kein Seitenstechen bekommen, nicht schnell laufen, ja, der Bus kommt, ja, der Bus kommt, ja, das ist mein Bus, das ist mein Bus, aber ich will keine Seitenstelle bekommen. Aber ich dachte auch neulich, ich kann diese Armhochgeste nie machen, weil immer mein Shirt zu kurz ist, weil ich zu gross bin. Und dann dachte ich mir, so Ocean's Eleven oder so, so ein krasser Heistfilm. So, dann gehen die raus zu der Polizei, hauen die K.O. so, dann ziehen die deren Sachen an und laufen dann raus, als wären es dann die Polizisten.
Wenn ich dabei wäre, hätte ich so viel zu kurze.
Ich bin so ungeeignet für so eine Heistgruppe, weil immer wenn ich so Leute überwältigen würde, wenn ich dann deren Sachen anziehen würde, würde ich dann zurück ins Casino kommen,
so komplett baufrei, mit so ganz kurzen Höschen. Du bist ein bisschen gross für einen Stormtrooper. Ja. Ich kann es euch mal zeigen, was passieren würde. Achtung, das würde passieren. Das heißt, danke schön, das heißt, ich hoffe, wir haben keine Einbrecher heute mit dabei. Wenn ihr seht, Hände hoch, kann ich mich kurz umziehen. Ja. Mache ich alles. Ich mache alles, was Sie wollen, aber ich würde mich kurz umziehen. Lassen Sie mich meinen Bademantel anlegen. Da ist mein ganzes Geld drin. Hamburg, wir hatten eine fantastische Zeit mit euch. Es tut uns sehr leid, dass wir heute aufgrund der ganzen Covid-Sache können wir nicht mit euch Fotos machen. Sehr, sehr schade leider.
Es ist total leid, normalerweise würden wir gerne mit euch draußen noch ein bisschen labern und Fotos machen. Das können wir nicht machen. Wir haben aber eine ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz grosse Überraschung. Ja. Geht's noch für euch? Ich weiß nicht, gibt's Podcast-Suche für Hörer und Hörerinnen hier im Raum? Hat's noch mal jemand? Habt ihr … Oh, das ist überrascht, okay, mehr als ich dachte, mehr als ich dachte. Habt ihr vielleicht Folge 266 gehört, hinter dem Mikrofon? Oh, tatsächlich, tatsächlich. Das überrascht, das war unsere Musical-Folge, in der wir einige Songs gesungen haben. Und wir dachten heute als kleines Bonus, als kleine Überraschung, möchten wir euch ein bisschen was vorspielen. Und dafür brauchen wir natürlich einen Gast, den wir hier begrüssen dürfen. Vielleicht ist euch schon aufgefallen, dass die ganze Zeit ein riesiger Flügel auf der Bühne steht. Wir mussten uns so zusammenreißen. Und an diesen gehört natürlich nur ein Mann und es ist der Mann, der unsere Songs geschrieben hat für das Musical. Viel, viel Applaus für den Brandiosen Albrecht Schrader! Schrader! Albrecht! Hallo Albrecht, das ist Albrecht Schrader. Vielen Dank, Albrecht, und Albrecht wäre das besonders nicht möglich gewesen. Die ganze Saison ist geschrieben. Wow, und er kann offensichtlich einen Akkord spielen, schau mal. Wir sind gespannt, was noch so folgt. Vielen Dank, dass du heute da bist. Ja, danke auch sehr.
Und zwar haben wir jetzt nur eine kleine Überraschung für euch.
Wir tun euch das jetzt einfach mal an. Thank you. Jede Woche Dienstag um zehn im Studio, seit sieben langen Jahren läuft das so. Ich setz mich an den Tisch und steck das Mikrokabel ein,
klapp den Rechner auf und Florentin kommt rein.
Ich sag Hallo.
Jede Woche Dienstag um elf im Studio, seit dreihundertdreifolgen geht das so. Ich geh in den Raum und zieh die Jacke erst mal aus, schau Stefan an und plötzlich fällt mir auf.
Er sitzt mir gegenüber, ich weiss gar nicht, wer wirklich ist.
Seit Jahren UFO-Brüder, kenn den Titzler, aber Stefanie. Hinter dem Mikrofon, ich sitze hier und du da. Hinter dem Mikrofon sind wir uns niemals nah wir reden und reden aber sagen uns nichts ich sehe nicht mal nicht mal dein Gesicht hinter dem Mikrofon.
Ich frag ihn, was Privates, das mach ich eigentlich nie, doch alles, was dann kommt, ist die Ironie. Auf der Tour bekommen wir gemeinsam den Applaus, nach der Schau gehen wir allein nach Haus. Hat er eine Freundin, wo wohnt er und was hört er für Musik? Wir wissen
nichts übereinander, ich hoffe so sehr, er ist kein Antisemit hinter dem Mikrofon hat alles angefangen.
Hinter dem Mikrofon sind wir schon viel zu lang.
Wir sind die Sind wir schon viel zu lang.
Wir reden uns reden, aber sagen uns nichts.
Ich seh nicht mal dein Gesicht hinter dem Mikrofon. Vielleicht ist unsere Zeit gekommen, haben die deutschen Podcastpreis gewonnen. Was bleibt uns denn noch? Hinter dem Mikrofon. Kann mich ganz auf Yoga konzentrieren. Dann kann ich mehr für Warcraft 3 trainieren, für wen hier kommt gerade noch eine Nachricht und plötzlich wird mir klar, alles was uns wichtig ist, das liegt im Grunde da, hinter dem Mikrofon. Ihr seid, was uns noch hier hält. Hinter dem Mikrofon liegt eine ganze Welt. Vielen Dank, Albrecht Schrader.
Dankeschön, Hamburg.
Vielen Dank, Hamburg.
Vielen Dank.
Musical, wir haben mal Musical gesucht.
Yes.
Albrecht Schrader, Brüder und Herren.
Prost Applaus.
Vielen Dank an euch.
Schönen Abend.
Vielen Dank.
Na, na, kam her, komm her! Dankeschön! Ihr wart fantastisch, habt noch einen schönen Abend, macht's gut, danke Albrecht! Das war das Podcast-Sufu mit Stefan Tietze! Vielen Dank! Und Florentin Will! Dankeschön! und Albrecht Stader, und Rebecca, und David, und alle!
Vielen Dank!
Und ich würde sagen, wir heben ab! Applaus